making it through the zombie apocalypse
means putting your survival instincts to
the test and putting your weekly
manicure on hold until things blow over
but while these survivors on The Walking
Dead look like they haven't seen a hot
shower in a while the actors playing
them are doing just fine in the personal
hygiene Department but you smell very
very good oh thank you shampoo I do I do
stick with us while we check out what
the cast of AMC's The Walking Dead looks
like in real life and in case you were
wondering there are some minor undead
spoilers for The Walking Dead seasons 1
through 6 ahead Andrew Lincoln as the
first character introduced in the series
premiere of The Walking Dead in 2010
Rick Grimes started his undead Odyssey
is your typical clean-cut sheriff's
deputy but being constantly brutalized
and watching your friends and loved ones
to come to the horrors of the apocalypse
can change a man and Rick's difficulty
coming to grips with the world's
encroaching chaos is physically embodied
by his hair and beard which grew
increasingly more disheveled before
reaching its magnificent peak in season
5 fortunately the dashing Andrew Lincoln
has little in common with his tormented
character beyond his rugged good looks
where Rick is a hard-boiled Guardian
Lincoln is a fun-loving guy who likes to
play pranks on his castmates and who
keeps his facial forests well under
control Norman Reedus Daryl Dixon is
more comfortable on a hog than in an
armored car and his appearance parallels
his no-nonsense approach to survival
with scraggly locks in that trademark
squint Daryl's look is a
post-apocalyptic take on biker chic
except when he's wearing this fabulous
poncho in real life Reedus is pretty
much indistinguishable from his
character albeit was slightly less dirt
and blood caked on his clothing it
doesn't take much effort to transform
Reedus who like daryl really takes his
motorcycle seriously into his fictional
walker wacking counterpart but in real
life Reedus is a sweetheart who loves to
surprise his cast mates with kisses lots
of kisses Chandler Riggs this young
actor has undergone major changes since
season 1 both as a result of the
nightmare unfolding around him but also
as a result of puberty which is a whole
different kind of nightmare Riggs was
first cast as Carl at the tender age of
10 and 7 years later he's got some
battle scars like the gaping hole where
his eyeball used to be a view
Seanie I mean have you looked in the
mirror that is gross as hell but take
away the bandage or the gruesome
prosthetic knock off the cowboy hat and
here's what Chandler looks like in real
life complete with that signature shag
haircut which he's contractually
obligated to keep Danai gurira
this sword wielding warrior took the
screen by storm in season 3 and forget
what she said about putting fashion on
hold in the apocalypse because Michonne
kicks Walker ass in style slicing and
dicing and distressed skinny jeans and
her signature sleeveless leather vest
Guerrera really brings her character to
life so it came as a minor shock to
superfans everywhere when they realized
that the actress has always worn her
hair short even shaving it for her role
in Marvel's Black Panther film that's
right those locks are a wig and while
they're not the most comfortable thing
to wear while filming in the Georgia
heat gurira says they have their perks
probably one of the most user-friendly
hairstyles a black girl can have in the
apocalypse Steven Yeun Blinn may be best
remembered for the skull crack heard
around the world when he was also the
group's moral compass his practical
no-frills style was an echo of his
attitude but in real life actor Steven
Yeun is a much more dapper dresser and
much less likely to show up covered in
zombie guts at his most casual though he
still has a lot in common with his
character right down to the baseball cap
Melissa McBride
thanks to her friendship with early
Walking Dead showrunner Frank Darabont
this casting director turned actress was
a shoo-in for the role of Carol a fan
favorite for her cunning and loyalty to
the team Carol short silver hair has
become an emblem of her journey from an
abused wife to an ice-cold killer when
it's time to transform mcbride into a
camera-ready survivor it's just a
question of mussing up her hair popping
a rifle in her hands and smearing a
little dirt on her face the rest is pure
acting talent lauren cohan from farmer's
daughter to toughest nails widow cohan's
character maggie has transformed since
her season two debut into a savvy leader
of the hilltops militia and traded in
her farm friendly look for baseball caps
hunting jackets and handgun holsters but
in real life lauren cohan is all glitz
and glamour at least compared to her
kneecap busting counterpart cohan who
modeled for Richard Branson's failed
apparel company virgin clothing before
hitting at big in Hollywood
regularly opts for designer clothing and
elegant makeup rather than the
apocalyptic rags in Maggie's wardrobe
nobody wants to take their work home
with them right lynnie James between his
mental breakdown his fling with pacifism
and his chaotic collapse back into
homicide after Richards betrayal of the
kingdom Morgan is a ticking time bomb in
makeshift armor but actor Lenny James on
the other hand is one dapper son of a
gun
after graduating from Guildhall School
of Music and Drama
the English actor had a long career on
screen before finding his way to the
walking dead although there's at least
one coveted role he still hasn't gotten
to play I would like to have been Batman
meanwhile like the Caped Crusader
Morgan's looking a little wild around
the eyes these days but James is out and
about rocking a pair of dark frames and
a single earring Jeffrey Dean Morgan
whether you hate to love him or love to
hate him this man changed the game as
the zombie apocalypses Louisville
Slugger swinging sociopath and we'll be
darned if he doesn't look awfully
stylish even in that dastardly debut
that had fans sobbing into their barf
bags in his role as negan Morgan rocks a
leather jacket that suggests a
pre-apocalypse pension for punk rock and
a red scarf that has inspired countless
articles speculating about its meaning
in real life Jeffrey Dean Morgan doesn't
share the same sensibilities as his
character and with good reason
since he's confessed that he finds the
role itself extremely emotionally taxing
that might be why he grows out his
whiskers during The Walking Dead's
offseason the better to distance himself
from the villainous clean-shaven negan
Josh McDermitt as the zombie dramas most
knowledgeable survivor Eugene can make
poison and craft bullets and betray his
friends to become negan's right-hand man
happily the actor who plays him is the
total opposite of his TV counterpart
let's do this one rapid-fire actor Josh
McDermott's natural hair color is blonde
that's not his real voice and the mullet
he sported when he first arrived on the
show was a wig no I have this other
acting job called my personal life that
I want to not have the mullet and
although recent photos suggest that he's
starting to embrace Eugene's hairdo as a
way of life if not his penchant for
cargo vests but most importantly Josh
McDermitt is nothing like the cowardly
Eugene which means that if you see him
on the street you should be nice and not
yell at him Khary Payton as the show
scenery-chewing community theater actor
turned king Payton has undergone a
dramatic makeover himself to play
Ezekiel one of the series most
polarizing
characters the King sports a mane of
gray dreadlocks and regal garments fit
for an Elder Scrolls Emperor a look
that's totally in contrast with Payton
stripped down casual aesthetic in real
life this actor keeps things simple with
a shaved head and the best beard this
side of Game of Thrones Christian
Serratos it's hard to believe that
Christian Serratos shared a cafeteria
with the Twilight vampires before
stealing our hearts as the feisty Rosita
Espinosa when she joined the cast in
season 4
after the decimation of two of her
besties at the hands of negan Rosita
quickly became an outspoken proponent of
slaughtering the Savior's and swapped
out her trendy traveling outfit and
youthful pigtails for a more practical
look meanwhile off-camera Cerritos is
right at home on the red carpet and
usually wears designer duds that would
be totally impractical in a zombie
apocalypse Michael Cudlitz let's face it
Abraham's got a face only a mother could
love well and Rosita and Sasha and his
late wife Ellen okay so the big lug
actually gets a lot of love but between
the signature scowl the iconic mustache
and The Orange Box cut Abraham's lucky
he's got charm and a gift for
self-expression and Bailey shaved me
down all over
dolphins in real life fans of a will be
shocked to learn that actor Michael
Cudlitz is actually a natural blonde and
he's nowhere near as averse to sleeves
as the walking dead costume department
would have you believe Austin Emilio
after a botched attempt at stealing
medical supplies
Emilio's character Dwight had a close
encounter with a burning hot iron which
his knee gets preferred punishment for
disloyal saviors when he doesn't just
straight-up beat them to death
fortunately the melted face is purely
prosthetic in real life austin emilio
lacks both the disfiguring injury and
the haunted look of his walking dead
character and when he's not cleaning up
to walk the red carpet his preferred
style is skater chic in keeping with his
first career as a semi-professional
skateboarder Sonique while martin green
before being cast on star trek discovery
this actress spent five seasons playing
Sascha the walking dead character who
just couldn't catch a break
first she lost her brother Tyrese then
her boyfriend Bob met a bad end and
finally her romance with Abraham was cut
short before it could even begin at the
end of season six sasha sacrificed her
life to help turn the tables on the
scavengers in the saviour's and to
boldly go where no man had gone before
of course in real life
Martin green is just as devoted to her
family Asafa particularly the son she
gave birth to shortly after the show's
fifth season but don't be fooled by her
laid-back Apokolips style and permanent
ponytail offset this actress is all
about experimental glamour and gravity
defying hairstyles david morrissey this
actors performances Philip Blake better
known as the governor reminded audiences
that zombies weren't the only thing to
be afraid of during the end days with a
clean-cut appearance that masks some
seriously twisted sensibilities the
governor was a sinister figure even
before he put on the iconic eyepatch
that marked him as a true villain but
while david morrissey is just as
handsome as his walking dead character
in real life the similarities in there
for one thing he's a much snappier
dresser but more importantly the British
actor is such a warm friendly fellow
that his co-stars considered it a
privilege to be hunted by him that was
the funnest evening when he was trying
to kill me Seth Gilliam for all of his
errors in judgement Gilliam's father
Gabriel has since turned out to be a
loyal solid moral force within Rick's
band of survivors not to mention the
only person capable a frightening median
just by showing up Oh
crap you are creepy edge needless to say
Seth Gilliam doesn't wear a clerical
collar in real life but he's no stranger
to playing characters who shared
Gabriel's complexity you might have seen
him on the wire as sergeant Ellis Carver
who epitomized the potential for
positive change both as a human being
and as an officer of the law
Pollyanna McIntosh season seven of The
Walking Dead saw the introduction of a
new group to the mix the scavengers
a group of survivors with a love of
recycling and all things put it
unfortunately
this crew eventually betrayed Rick's
collective during a massive shootout
with the Savior's but we're glad they
showed up just for the pleasure of
meeting Macintosh's character an oddball
named Jadis who collects junkyard art
and staunchly refuses to conjugate her
verbs guns to take our deal still on
off-screen McIntosh is practically
unrecognizable as Jadis except for the
blonde bangs and post-apocalyptic dye
job that somehow manages to still look
glamorous and unlike her character the
actress speaks in complete sentences and
with an English accent it was really
exciting from start to finish thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]